[Music]
as disney announced this week the
filming of the new ahsoka series has
officially started you can see a photo
of the director's chair which given the
typical cowboy hat most certainly
belongs to director dave filoni it can
be assumed that felonio is very popular
among fans who will direct one or even
several episodes of this series although
details about this are not yet known the
fact that the 47 year old was chosen to
direct ahsoka is no mere coincidence
after all he was also in charge of the
first clone wars film in it ahsoka also
made her first appearance as a jedi
apprentice to anakin skywalker since
then filoni and his character have been
inseparable for this reason we think it
is likely that falloni will not direct
just any episode he will probably direct
the pilot episode right away this way as
the creator of the character he can set
the overall direction of the series
spider-man into the spider-verse
director peter ramsey will also be
responsible for at least one episode the
plot of the series is not known yet but
we can certainly expect appearances by
rosaria dawson as ahsoka dano hayden
christiansen as anakin skywalker and
natasha elio bordizzo as seven ran we
will also get to see ivana sagno mary
elizabeth winstead and ray stevenson in
as yet unknown roles a release date has
not been provided so far
it's been known for a long time that the
boys enjoys convincing viewers with
quirky humor and brutal violence now in
view of the imminent start of the third
season there is a new image that shows
two characters in an unusual way scene
are the two characters kimiko miyashiro
aka the female in search aka frenchie
played by karen fukuora and tilmer
capone this is indeed not a scene from
mamma mia but a very special episode of
the new season this one is supposed to
be designed similar to musical as you
can easily tell from the picture and the
dancing extras in the background in
addition the twitter account of den of
geek presented its new cover on which
you can see jensen echols a soldier boy
in the foreground the streaming release
of season 3 is scheduled for june 3rd
2022 on amazon prime there is further
news about this still untitled the voice
spin-off there has been a lot of
activity among the cast in recent weeks
as the project has lost a number of
leading actors a key factor there is the
fact that those responsible have
rewritten many of the characters again
these now no longer fit the originally
committed actors one of them is rhina
hardesty who is now substituted by
london thor apart from that many
newcomers were cast including derek liu
shelly khan and asa german also joining
the cast of three leading men arnold
schwarzenegger saw patrick
schwarzenegger's golden boy sean patrick
thomas as dr cadosa and marco pigassi as
polarity there's no release date for the
boys spin-off yet but we will of course
keep you posted for several months there
has been speculation that loki's season
2 will be filmed this summer the first
season played an important role in
shaping the mcu and therefore fans are
now eagerly awaiting the impact that the
open multiverse will have on the further
plot in the series via the
productionlist.com website it has now
been possible to pinpoint the concrete
kickoff date for the shooting and that
is on june 6 2022. besides that there
will be some changes behind the camera
first screenwriter michael waldron has
taken the place of his colleague eric
martin second there is also a substitute
for director kate herron namely the two
moon knight directors justin benson and
aaron morehead as for the cast
officially returning are tom hills nas
loki guggenbachera as radhana ranslayer
and on wilson as mobius and mobius more
actors are expected to be added to the
cast in the coming weeks sadly there is
no release date for loki season 2 yet
but a release during the coming year is
deemed likely
in just a few weeks thor love and
thunder will finally hit theaters those
responsible of those in the midst of
their marketing campaign and have some
interesting news to share this is also
the case with director taika waititi who
was recently available for interview
with empire magazine according to him
mighty thor played by natalie portman
was only included in the process of
writing the screenplay because the
return of jane to the story was found to
be extremely fitting and in the plot
about eight years had passed since thor
and mighty thor last met hence the
sudden reunion between the former couple
is a downright mind [ __ ] for thor and
keeping with this there was also a new
image to be admired showing the two main
characters in the superhero costumes
mighty thor is holding the hammer
mjolnir which means she has proven
herself worthy thor himself resorts to
the powerful stormbreaker though it is
not featured here just this side of
mighty thor is something special because
until now she was only spotted wearing a
helmet at the end of the recently
released trailer we are excited for more
news and look forward to the theatrical
release on july 8th 2022
when netflix released the drama series
cobra kai on the streaming service in
2018 surely nobody expected to have such
a staying power fans can soon look
forward to the fifth season as netflix
has released a brand new trailer the
plot is set to resume smoothly into
season 5 directly following the end of
the fourth season there's plenty of
potential for thrilling story lines with
events such as daniel larusso and chosen
taguchi teaming up against silver the
latter is trying to expand the cobra
kite dojo in the absence of john crease
in addition there are johnny lawrence
and robbie keane who both want to track
down the missing miguel diaz a large
part of the plot is to be based in
mexico fortunately the trailer also
revealed the official release date for
the fifth season of cobra kai which is
september 9 2022
in the recent past netflix has made
headlines for one thing in particular
the massive drop in its stocks now the
company announced a new subscription
model that they themselves had
considered out of the question for years
it's an option where you pay on a
somewhat lower price but have to watch
advertisements in return the launch of
this model is expected to happen very
fast for instance the company decided to
forego test markets in order to be able
to offer the new subscription plan
within the next six months they hope to
win back some lost subscribers as many
cancel their subscriptions due to the
constant price increases and the
lackluster content even though many
reacted rather mockingly to the
announcement this could be a real
opportunity for the streaming service to
win back former customers other
providers are more than capable of
competing and disney plus in particular
is one of the strongest contenders with
its constantly surpassed forecasts this
may be due to the consistently high
quality catalog of new movies and series
along with a more affordable pricing
unfortunately it is not known yet what
the cost of the new netflix model will
be we are still waiting for an official
statement in this regard what's your
opinion on netflix new subscription
model can you picture yourself watching
ads for less money or as a former
subscriber can you even imagine signing
up for a subscription again feel free to
let us know in the comments
with stream paramount achieved success
with fans and critics at the beginning
of the year shortly thereafter work
began on a sequel which will be the
sixth film in this scream franchise we
recently got news about the cast of
scream 6 and let me tell you it packs a
punch the cast includes melissa barrera
jasmine savoy brown mason gooding and
jenna ortega in addition the hollywood
reporter announced the signing of hayden
panettiere who already appeared in
stream 4 from 2011. there she played the
character kirby reed who had an
important role in the story how exactly
kirby will then be included in the plot
of the new movie is still unclear we
know at least that woodsboro will no
longer play a significant part in the
upcoming scream 6 since the 4 survivors
of the predecessor are long gone filming
starts this summer again under the
direction of matt bernalillo open and
tyler gillett while the script is once
again the work of james vanderbilt and
guy music on march 31 2023 this still
untitled stream 6 is said to have its
premiere in theaters
well those were the latest news for this
week but hold on there is more with our
new original video for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 you will be up to date on
this superhero sequel and of course you
shouldn't miss the first trailer for
avatar 2 the way of water we hope you
enjoy it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]